bonjour gideon coûte merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
arte france pour parler de de cette
hausse inhabituelle du taux de mortalité
en israël alors que le pays fait figure
de modèle en termes de vaccination
comment comment vous l'expliquez
bon d'abord des bonnes nouvelles ces
dernières jours depuis deux ou trois
jours et ce nombre est en chute mais
donc israël disant victime est victime
d'une décision
qui a été prise par d'autres et a aussi
aidé relativiser donc la situation est
de préférer la relance et de la vie et
économique et de la vie sociale au prix
d'un maintien si vous voulez d'un taux à
zéro et des
contaminations et il serait en outre
malgré cette situation là par exemple
est en train d
d'annuler les passes vaccinale est ce
qu'ils appelaient les passes blair en
israël et
toutes les autres églises ont
obligation
pourquoi et parce que
comme dans d'autres pays et la vague
d'eau micro et a
paru pas très pas très dangereux récents
comparaison avec les autres s était pour
les israéliens
l'état d'israël est les bons moments et
[Musique]
d'essayer donc 2
infléchir en paix est la politique donc
des septs et de cette modération et on
va voir si ça passe
il faut dire est que les taux de
contamination est arrivé par exemple les
24 % hier ce qui est ce qui - qui était
avant donc les autorités sanitaires
visent toujours et que c'est le bon
choix mais bien sûr il ya beaucoup de
contestations et contrition alors c'est
vrai que lowe's israël est pourtant un
des pays les plus vaccinée le planétaire
en france est en vigueur parce qu'il
faut inciter les gens à se faire
vacciner on croyait que la vaccination
protéger en tout cas trois doses pouvait
protéger de ce variant omikron des
formes graves en tout cas comment est-ce
que quelle conclusion on peut en tirer
est ce que c'est vous voulez la
vaccination finalement est si efficace
que ça contre le variant omicron et oui
oui elle protège toujours et c'est la
ville et les gens qui sont hospitalisés
sont pour la plupart des noms boxing a
quand même 20% des noms d'auxi né en
israël il faut pas l'oublier et ce sont
des personnes ou des personnes plus
âgées et vulnérables et donc la preuve
comme toujours donné que la vaccination
est beaucoup mieux et que la non
l'oxydation et ça se voit et d'en aimer
mais dans les nombres donc
d'hospitaliser est dans un état grave et
on cette pole est ce qu'il serait là
atteint son pic de contamination déjà
face aux variants omicron oui écouter
oui oui c'est ce qu'ils disent c'est ce
qu'ils disent maintenant dix ans on
descend de seppic là mais vous savez
partout on parle des pics et puis
peut-être en général et en france aussi
on n'y paraît il paraît qu'on en était
arrivé au piquet qui en connaissant
depuis il y à un plateau etc etc ce
qu'il faut dire que ces situations sont
toujours imprévisibles et rappelons nous
que ça dure déjà depuis deux ans et
chaque fois on nous a promis un pic puis
une chipie une descente et c'est parfois
ils se sont trompés tous ces
spécialistes là et de ses points de vie
oui c'est le dessin est de ces pics mais
il y aura peut-être un autre due à un
autre et brûlent explosé en collectant
les p t bonds ne marche pas tellement
aimé et en général il faut se méfier ce
n'est pas terminée tant que ce n'est pas
catherine est scott vu la situation le
pays maintient quand même l'allègement
de ces restrictions et continue dans ce
sens oui oui c'est certain maintenant il
ya des médecins qui est l'état des
choses maintenant il ya des médecins qui
sont contre ceux qui disent que les
hôpitaux les hôpitaux risquent de
nouveau être submergés mais pour
l'instant est temps qu'il y a
cette direction qui a prise là
la maladie donc
l'épidémie et ses décisions sont
maintenues mais bien un grand débat
public et à grande épopée publique et le
gouvernement doit s'expliquer tous les
jours sur sa politique merci beaucoup
gideon cous de nous avoir éclairé ce
matin sur la situation en israël situer